hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll i'm
sure that everyone listening knows that
the planet
the environment the biosphere of the
planet earth on which we live uh is in
trouble it has been suffering recently
in recent decades
largely due to activities caused by
human beings such as ourselves climate
change is a very very obvious example of
this often when we think about climate
change we think of the atmosphere
because we breathe it right the weather
the temperatures that we get in the
world around us it's more complicated
than that of course even if overall the
temperature is going up shifts in wind
patterns and other climate features can
make it colder or rainier or increase
the number of fires or hurricanes or
something like that and guess what the
ocean is very very involved in this the
ocean is a huge store of carbon dioxide
it's a store of biomass that helps us
process carbon dioxide and of course the
ocean also has a temperature and that
temperature is going to help regulate
the temperature of the atmosphere not to
mention the fact that there are ice
sheets that are melting and therefore
dumping into the ocean
furthermore it's not just climate change
that is affecting our oceans uh we are
dumping garbage into the oceans plastics
both big and small we are fishing and
taking life out of the ocean in
incredible numbers so
nobody in the past few decades has been
a more consistent and compelling voice
for
fixing and protecting our oceans than
today's guest sylvia earle sylvia earle
obviously has an incredible resume in
the unlikely event that you are not
familiar with her work i encourage you
to google or go to the show notes on
preposterousuniverse.compodcast and
click on some of these links
for decades now since she got her phd uh
and has become interested in both the
scientific study of the oceans and life
in the oceans and also their
preservations so sylvia spent weeks of
her life
on the ocean floor either in pressure
suits or in underwater environments she
still holds a number of records for the
longest
dive or or walk under certain
circumstances and she served as an
activist she was for a long for a short
time i should say she was the chief
scientist at noaa the national oceanic
and atmospheric administration i should
say a short time because uh she didn't
last very long this was during the first
george bush administration and she
resigned because she realized that she
could be a more effective advocate as a
private citizen than as a government
official
and she still to this day you know she's
she's been around for a while and she's
as active as ever uh she has a new
organization mission blue that is
dedicated to protecting our oceans
because despite the fact that the oceans
are most of the area of our globe we
might neglect them you know we don't
think of them as much when we think
about the environment and what we're
doing and what we're doing as you'll
hear in this podcast uh is pretty bad
and pretty extensive and it's one of
these conversations that if you're not
already plugged into what's going on it
will make you stop and think uh and
think about what we're doing both
individually and
as a society as governments to protect
our oceans and you know there's a chance
that silk is a despite the fact that we
are doing these terrible terrible things
to our oceans she is just a relentlessly
optimistic person and so she spins it as
the new generation has an opportunity to
do something amazing namely to save our
planet and she encouraged us to do that
the planet both the blue part as well as
the green part the oceans as well as the
land so this is a call to action as well
as a cautionary tale if you want some
more details you can check out sylvia's
new book called national geographic
ocean a global odyssey and as she
discusses in the podcast part of the
impetus behind the book was
taking advantage as it were of the
pandemic to sort of step back and think
uh not just keep diving into the ocean
and doing science and doing advocacy but
really try to put the big picture
together and think about where we are
and where we're gonna go with that let's
go
[Music]
sylvia earle welcome to the mindscape
podcast it's so great to be on board
so i really want to get into these
questions about the oceans and their uh
ecology and their environment and the
bad things that we're doing to them and
the good things we could try to do but
first i can't you know get away without
taking advantage of the fact that we
have you here
and you know you have a set of
experiences that most of us don't have i
mean could you just share a little bit
about what it's like on the ocean floor
you know you've spent time down there
and i think most our listeners have not
well the ocean is actually not the
bottom nor the top it's that part in in
between
fair enough
it's the wet part yeah
and
i have
i think just begun to
explore
for myself
and
all of us we're just i think at the edge
of the greatest era
of exploring the blue part of
of the planet
and
i wish i could take everybody
out
take the plunge get in there my
mother actually waited until she was 81
before she put on
a mask and
and looked at the ocean from the inside
out and if she were here
she would say
don't wait until you're 81 but if you
if you are
it's not too late
dive in
go
go see for yourself
the
the joy of getting to
see
that the ocean is alive it's just full
of the most wonderful creatures
you know on the land it's pretty
exciting if you see
a wild bird up close
uh the one that would come and
and
look at you in the ocean
the wild things come and look at you all
the time
they're curious and
they're abundant
fish
go out of their way to
to come and see who is who are you what
are you doing down here
well at the practical level uh do you
have any advice like literally i'm
listening to you and i have never
done this i've really never gone below
not yet exactly right so i mean what
should i do if i wanted to just without
making too much of a lifetime commitment
as you have done to experience what it's
like there
well
a good first
way to take the plunge is
as my mother did
with a mask that fits so that it doesn't
leak and
if you wear glasses there's so many ways
now to
get
an insert in
in
a face mask
that enables you to see as clearly
underwater as you do on the land
and that's i think the number one
priority get a good face mask and after
that
flippers help yeah it enables
enables you to swim
faster even in the swimming pool and you
can practice in the swimming pool and
see wow you can literally
move
with greater speed and dexterity if you
have those
and again it's nice to get some that
really are comfortable on your feet
and the snorkel it takes a little use to
getting used to to
have something in your mouth
that you breathe through
like dolphins
have a hole in the top of their head
that they breathe through when they come
up to the surface this is something like
that you know you put a snorkel on so
you can keep your face down and breathe
through
the snorkel that projects out of the
water
it seems a little awkward at first but
it doesn't take long i actually went
diving with mr rogers
in the florida keys mr rogers the famous
ambassador for all things in the world
with children
and
he
he did a good job of explaining to kids
what a snorkel does and
how
how easy it is and what a gift it is to
be able to breathe
as you're cruising along on the surface
yeah but then if you want to go a little
bit deeper and stay a little bit longer
just try scuba there are scuba shops
all over
the country all over the world
that will take pleasure in introducing
you to what it's like to
breathe
on the bottom of a swimming pool or in
in the ocean
and of course there's a lot more to see
in the ocean than in the swimming pool
and at the other end of the
technological spectrum once we get to
the scientific research etc like what is
the state of the art for how we are
exploring
uh both the ocean and the ocean floor
well i love getting into a little
submarine
that
enables
people
to go
well presently
it's possible with the technology that
now exists to go to the deepest part of
the ocean which is
about as deep in the ocean as people fly
high in the sky on a commercial aircraft
seven miles
or
11 kilometers
and the the idea that we now have the
capacity to
to get anywhere in the ocean
at least for a while
uh
hours not weeks but
living underwater is another tool that
is available
i i've stayed under water in an
underwater laboratory now on 10
different occasions
and literally you can live underwater
for days or even weeks at a time
so you become
part of the system
day or night you can go out and visit
with the creatures who live there
are there ongoing underwater
laboratories in operation right now well
back in the 1970s when i first tried an
underwater laboratory
there was the expectation
that there would be a lot of them
going forward actually
that dream has not come true
but there is aquarius the underwater
laboratory
that is down in the florida keys okay
where aquanauts can
spend
days or even weeks at a time and
astronauts actually
train there
to see and experience
what weightlessness is like
it's true in
space and of course
you can
simulate that yourself with scuba
you can stand on one finger you could be
like a ballerina
do backflips
and
and not feel
the least bit of stress in in doing so
and is aquarius uh mostly a scientific
research institution well
you perhaps hear that chicken in the
background i do hear chickens that's
okay that's all part of the color
colorful background we'll put up with
that
yeah
most of
well i would say that all of my
time underwater
has
been
useful scientifically because
as a scientist i'm always on full alert
i want us i want to know everything
about everything
the way little kids want to know
everything about everything
and
and then to share the view
and communicate not just with my fellow
scientists but with the rest of the
world but on the other hand
every dive is also a pleasure sure
it's it's not exactly recreational but
it certainly is fun
there's clearly a
analogy at least that you've already
mentioned between
space exploration and ocean exploration
i'm as a cosmologist as in part of my
day job uh i'm much more familiar with
the space side of things so is there a
similar debate with ocean exploration as
there is with space exploration about
human-centered exploration versus
robotic or you know sensors on the on
the in the ocean like how much data are
we collecting just through remote
sensing rather than actually sending
people down there
well
i'm intrigued by these
these questions about do we really need
to have humans up in the sky
do we really need to have humans down in
the ocean
i think the answer to that is
a resounding
but of course
we need all of the
ways and means available to us
to
to experience and explore whether it's
going up or going down they
they're advantages to having robots that
never get tired although they do wear
out
yeah
they need maintenance
but
they
generally have
longer endurance
and if you lose a robot it's kind of no
big deal it's a dollar loss but it's not
a human life loss
and that concern
is always there whether we're talking
about astronauts or those who explore
the ocean
but
the difference between sending a camera
and sending an instrument and
actually being there yourself
is huge
that we under
rate
perhaps our
our ability to be
surprised
and
our ability to follow a hunch
you kind of see something out of the
corner of your eye and you turn and
go check ch check it out a programmed
robot
cannot do that and even with a remotely
operated system where there is a human
in the loop just happened to be up on
the surface
driving the vehicle just like the mars
rover
had human
operators and
observers
looking through the camera eyes of the
rover
and
you know some of these rovers whether
it's
on other
parts of the solar system or in the deep
sea
are pre-programmed or they have the
the
sensory equipment to be able to operate
on their own
many of them
do have
take commands from
a human yeah and bring information back
live
that's still
not the same as
actually being there
i mean i i sometimes
make an analogy it's one thing to be
at a fine restaurant
dining
drinking the wine
having a conversation whatever it is
it's another to send a camera
right now we are communicating with
in a way that is great this is
almost
but not quite as good
as
sitting across the table from you i
would like to be able to see your
chicken and say hi this is what uh you
know i'm missing out with this
technological you hear a very happy
rooster here pretty soon okay good
stem isn't just about doing calculations
or even about using computers it's a way
of thinking it teaches kids how to
problem solve work together think
critically and build the innovations
that will shape our future not only that
but according to the department of
commerce most jobs are growing at a rate
of four percent while stem jobs are
going at 27
with id tech the world leader in stem
education your kids will explore science
tech engineering and math topics not
covered in school as they are prepared
for a future that demands literacy in
these crucial fields right now idtech is
offering a great deal you can save 150
on weekly small group semesters or get
started with a one-on-one tutoring
session for just 49
so go to idtech.com mindscape right now
and use the code mindscape to save a
hundred and fifty dollars on weekly
small group semesters for a limited time
you can also get started with a
one-on-one tutoring session for just
forty nine dollars that's code mindscape
at id tech dot com slash mindscape to
save 150
and your child can start learning online
from a live instructor right now
idtech.com
mindscape
so i mean maybe we can give the
listeners a a feeling for
the
i guess the ecology of what it's like
under the water because we we have a
intuition or an experience here on earth
that there are forests there are deserts
right there are different kinds of
climates and different kinds of terrains
how similar is it uh under the ocean is
the ocean floor are there deserts where
there's nothing on the ocean floor or is
there life everywhere there uh
do is there more aquatic life near the
land and so forth well from the surface
the ocean looks pretty much the same
today as it did
throughout all pre-produced
history of the ocean i suppose but
once you get under the surface the one
thing that strikes you is
there
there's life
life there's life everywhere from the
surface
to the greatest steps
and it's only
in fairly recent times that we've been
able to verify the existence of life
from the surface all the way down to the
bottom and even
beneath the bottom of the ocean where
water trickles down
through
cracks and crevices in the ocean floor
and
microbes
little guys
live as much as
a mile beneath the surf
beneath the bottom of the ocean oh wow
microbes but they're alive it's
part of what makes
makes life makes earth earth have those
use
amazing
bacteria and rqe as a part of the system
a very basic part of
life on earth but of course they're also
big things in the ocean the biggest
creature
that has ever
lived as far as we know blue whales
they're ocean creatures
adapted for
a life where their great bulk their huge
bodies as much as 100 feet long
can be
lifted be
the
you know made
not well buoyed up is the very word i
guess um
in the ocean suspended in the sea
they'd have a hard time
uh moving that much bulk
yeah on the land so if i were to take uh
a boat uh just a thousand miles in a
random direction here in the pacific
ocean and bring my little submarine and
go all the way down to the bottom at a
random spot on the pacific ocean floor
uh there would be life hanging out
absolutely
absolutely where there's water
there's likely to be life there's
there can be water without life but
there's no life without water
and most of earth's water 97 of it is
ocean
and the
fact that everywhere we've looked in the
ocean there is
microbial life
and if you look at a big chunk of ocean
you'll see big chunks of life
and
it's
not just rocks and water out there it's
a living system
i think that's the exciting thing that
all these things are connected yeah
we're connected to it as well if we
think that
we're not a part of
of
the living ocean
just ask yourself well where does air
come from where does water that falls
as rain sleet and snow where does it
come from
well it's the water cycle
that
most of it
evaporates from the surface of the ocean
into clouds and then falls back on land
and sea
the oxygen cycle
where does where does it come from
well it has taken living
systems
photosynthetic organisms
mostly in the ocean
before there were
trees and ferns and mosses on the land
there
was life in the ocean
again the small things the little guys
that do the heavy lifting
over many millions of years and they
continue right up to the present moment
generating oxygen
capturing carbon
really an important part not only of the
oxygen cycle that makes it possible for
us to breathe and for large animals
everywhere
to exist but also
capturing carbon
and generating food we're now able to
link as never before the role of
living organisms of course on the land
but especially
in the ocean
to climate
all of the carbon
and where is most of the carbon well
most of the earth is
most of the living part of the planet
is
is ocean
in the carbon cycle
driven by
by
photosynthesis capturing carbon dioxide
out of the atmosphere
converting it to sugar converting it to
food
it gets converted to
zooplankton food for them that in turn
become food for little fish
to become food for bigger fish
for whales and for some of us
and we're all carbon-based units too
when you think about
star trek
find the carbon-based units scotty
[Laughter]
so looking for light yeah
yeah so the ocean plays a huge role in
the carbon cycle um uh you know con so i
want to get this right because again i'm
not a biologist not an ecologist um it
it's it's not the ocean water it's the
life in the ocean
that is converting carbon dioxide into
oxygen is that true is that right
carbon dioxide and water yields
sugar yeah and and oxygen is a byproduct
yeah okay it's a simple photosynthesis
um
formula that
i love it that kids are learning this
early in their education but when you
think in the history of humankind
the knowledge about what error is
that it's mostly
nitrogen
about 80
about 20 percent
oxygen
and just enough carbon dioxide and other
gases
like helium and
neon a few things that are lurking in
what we breathe
and owing to our action there's a lot of
other stuff there too
and things you don't want to know about
that
they come back to haunt us even even
microplastics
nanoplastics the things that we have
generated which are great these
synthetic materials serve humankind very
well but
ah
when we throw them away they don't go
away they stick around yeah like the
fishing nets that were produced out of
these new light materials back in the
1960s
when they get lost or discarded
they don't go away
they're still out there clogging the
ocean
killing things
and when they do break down
it
they still don't go away right down to
the molecular level and that's those
little
tiny fragments
nanoplastics that are
really too small to be seen except with
a microscope
they are light enough so that they get
lofted into the atmosphere and we do
find it in the water we drink find them
in the even in the air we breathe what
is it that in your mind we don't know
about the oceans that is most important
to know like what are the big scientific
agenda questions in in learning more
about the ocean i think the most
important
discovery
well there are two
things the magnitude of our ignorance
we still
are at the edge of the greatest era of
exploration ever but i think from a
human standpoint
our existence is dependent
on the existence not just of the
water in the ocean but the fact that
it's a living system it's the living
ocean that makes life on earth
land and sea both possible that includes
us no ocean no life no ocean
no us no blue no green
so
i you know
one of the things that
i really value
about the terrible
2020 year of the pandemic
was a time
when i was able to sort of kick back and
reflect
on
the questions of the sort that you're
asking
and to try to
gather information what do we really
know what don't we know about the ocean
right
and
and incorporate that in a series of
sea stories if you will the story of the
ocean
in a book that is just coming out this
year for me
although
largely of course the pandemic was
terrible
and
for me
traveling the world and diving
much of the time
exploring i had to just give it up for a
while yeah when i dived into
into
the history of life on earth
and
i i hadn't taken time
for decades to just
kick back and
and think
and wonder
and try to
put it all together in ways that
actually until right about now
we couldn't do what is now possible to
to connect the dots to see how one thing
relates to another and to really
try to answer that question so why
should we care about the ocean
what has bhushan ever done for me
it keeps you alive
that's a starter
thank you ocean
yes
but then what what don't we know like
what are we what are we uh
are there big like so again if i talk
about
space or physics i can say well we have
this uh particle accelerator or this
spacecraft going to europa to look for
life like what are what are the big
science projects to that will hopefully
teach us new things about the ocean in
the years to come
looking for life in the ocean
is a big one
there was a 10-year project called the
census of marine life
from
2000-2010
where
scientists thousands of scientists from
around the world
made a point of trying to look at museum
records
of old wailing logs scientific notebooks
and gathering dust on a shelf try to
mine all the
the bits and pieces of knowledge that
were
sitting about and pull it together to
know something about
what we have known what what was known
about the ocean in times past and then
at the same time to deploy ships to
explore
the current state of the ocean and
further to imagine
the future of life in the ocean
and to try to answer that question what
don't we know yeah
and i think the answer to that is
just about everything
we're just scratching the surface
literally
so that
while that 10-year effort
really
was a
giant step in terms of
getting to know
more about
our neighbors who lives in the ocean and
what do they mean what do they do
i think that the fact that we
we have
found more species
of animals mostly insects on the land
then in the ocean
they're only about 15 major divisions of
animal life
that occur on the land
when you think
most people when they think animals they
focus on vertebrates yeah sure cats and
dogs and horses and sometimes they
remember to include people
with vertebrates
and we have
you know fish or vertebrates and frogs
and lizards and stuff
but
the great majority of life even on the
land
are creatures with no backbones the
invertebrates
use spiders and earthworms and snails
and of course all those insects
but
in the ocean
i mean
all of the major divisions of animal
life on the order of
nearly 35
categories of life that are distinctive
enough that they get
a distinctive
status as a phylum
of animals
and
the phylum that includes vertebrates
also includes a few other
kinds of
almost vertebrate animals called
chordates
the beginnings of backbones
but
when you think
that most of life on earth doesn't have
a backbone i mean in terms of
sheer volume
let alone diversity
so there are whole categories of life
like
nearly all categories of life are in the
ocean
only about half have some representation
on the land i mean there are no starfish
on the land or in fresh water but there
are lots of them
and in the ocean
not just
sea stars but they're relatives
again they're
divisions within divisions
but
the diversity of life in the sea is
is
it's just staggering
and and the abundance too it's where
when you think that's where the water is
97
of earth's water and where there's water
there's likely to be life
and we're the odd ones
we live out of the water most of life on
earth lives in the water and you've
already mentioned the nanoplastics but
uh how is this changing in recent
decades mostly due to human activity i
mean how is the
the set of living beings and the whole
ecosystem under the water uh being
altered by our activities well it's a
question that is
front and center in the minds of
scientists right now and many of them
who are
really trying to figure out okay so now
we know
we have plasticized the earth
one way or the other
so much plastic in the ocean
and
related synthetic materials
that
have been a boon to humankind i mean
think of all the ways that we use
plastics in buttons in our computer
systems plastic bags plastic cups you
name it it's hard to
move anywhere without encountering
one or many of these synthetic materials
but they don't go away that's part of
their
their
usefulness that they they're durable and
they're relative
to
many other substances they're they're
considered to be inexpensive but
they're not when you put the real cost
of
their existence on the balance sheet
what do we do with them
once they've
escaped into the ocean because we've put
them there
there's a cost
to
recovering them there's a cost
that we're just beginning to
try to factor in what what are they
doing to us
it's one thing
to get entangled in plastic
hundreds of thousands literally hundreds
of thousands of
seabirds turtles dolphins whales
seals sea lions otters
and of course
fish and this great spectrum of
invertebrate life gets
gets tangled
and killed
by the debris
just sheer
physical entanglement and also
a turtle eats a plastic bag it's not
very good for it
and
whales are coming ashore stuffed
with
in some cases
hundreds of pounds of plastic that
they've
maybe not deliberately but incidentally
dentally sure
taken in when they
when they eat a fish that's tangled in
plastic that plastic goes inside the
whale
so
that's one
example but
another concern is
chemically
what might be
happening
to
the creatures who
engulf
the nanoplastics or the
microplastics or the big chunks of
plastic
sometimes the big chunks displace enough
of the
space in the stomach of a creature that
they they literally starve because
they can't get enough
space on their stomachs to hold
no nutritious food yeah
their stomach is
is greatly
diminished in size
the capacity because of all the plastic
true with baby birds
uh seabirds that their parents
stuff them with
things like
well bits of plastic
cigarette lighters and
toothbrushes and
toy soldiers that have floated into the
ocean
i mean i'm not making this up there are
places
where seabirds nest
all over the world where
the
little birds hatch and the parents go
out to sea and they pick up things that
look nutritious
and bring them back and feed them to
their babies
and the babies get so stuffed with bits
of plastic that there's no room for food
and they simply die
and they're they're feathers you see
little piles of fluffy feathers where a
baby seabird has consumed so much
plastic that you see feathers surrounded
by
piles of
this plastic stuff
but
we don't have a real answer yet about
the
impact on human health
to
inhaling or engulfing
nanoplastics
or
microplastics that now appear
in the air
in
water
in the coffee you drink in
the beer whatever it is wherever there's
water
it's it's a scary thought but
that the actual impact is is simply a
question mark i mean i think it's
probably safe to say that
if you have a choice you'd rather not
be taking in these
bits of material that don't exist in
nature
that now exist
in us
you're not afraid of homework you like
to do your own research you spend a lot
of time down some pretty deep wikipedia
wormholes but if your search for the
right people for your company is coming
up dry there's a resource you haven't
tapped into yet if you're hiring you
need indeed indeed it's a hiring partner
that gets you what you really want a
short list of quality candidates as fast
as possible because you can do it all
attract interview and hire all at indeed
indeed is an unbelievably powerful
hiring partner you don't have to
struggle on your own to find quality
candidates indeed can help you hire the
right people right now indeed partners
with you on every step of the hiring
process so you can find talent with the
skills you need through tools like
indeed instant match assessments and
virtual interviews so get started right
now with a 75 sponsored job credit to
upgrade your job post at indeed.com
mindscape get a 75 credit at indeed.com
mindscape that's indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through december
31st terms and conditions apply need to
hire you need indeed
and and what about the just impact of
overfishing or or other
uh
sort of commercial farming of the sea
kinds of things i mean my vague
impression is that we've killed off a
lot of the stalks of fish and shellfish
and and so forth but uh what what is the
situation there it's one of the things
that i
dived into into my
year of deep thinking
and trying to articulate it in a
in a positive way for
the
national geographic
book it's
ocean a global odyssey
where the first part is literally about
the story of the ocean how did it come
to be
and how did life in the ocean come to be
how did we come to be
but then transitioning to our
our role
of the role of the ocean and climate the
role of ocean
as a source of
food and products
the way we used to look at whales as as
pounds of meat and barrels of oil
but we've shifted and i've been a
witness to the shift i served for a
while when i was chief scientist at noaa
i served on the international whaling
commission before
the agreement came into place to
to put a moratorium on the commercial
extraction killing of whales
and
now
witnesses change the whales were just
i mean wheelers were the heroes and
whales were the product
of
of
something that people valued for money
and a source of food
now we look at them
as societies as treasured fellow
creatures with with families with
personality
with language
we think of them
with a in a totally different
way now that we know what we know that
we could not know before and have these
efforts been successful
have these efforts been successful are
the whale populations recovering from
that overfishing as some of the whale
populations are recovering
like the gray whales
in california and mexico
going up to canada they
they have significantly rebounded from
where they were
at the low point when it was thought
with a few hundred of them remaining
that they might just disappear
but they have come back so that they're
now
thousands
not hundreds that's something yeah
the biggest threat now is not that we
spear them or harpoon them
but rather that we
we are taking their food yeah and
there's some skinny whales out there
because we were competing with them for
food
and also
because they get tangled
in the junk that we throw into the ocean
and
poisoning the ocean too that the ocean
chemistry is
changing because
of what we're putting in and what we're
taking out so it's
not as the ocean is not as safe for them
or for other marine life today as it has
been in times past
but i think the good news is
we can see the cause and effect
we can see that
there are fewer
sharks in the ocean now
by a lot from the time when i was a
child when
you know people who were afraid of
sharks
and they used to
warn me when i started diving the ocean
watch out they're man-eaters out there
and then i thought i don't qualify so
you're safe
but whales have to worry i mean sharks
have to worry now because
we eat them we ca we kill them
that the ratio of how many how many
sharks actually
eat humans or take a bite out of us
rarely does a shark actually consume a
human a few people like i don't know
three or four maybe six a year
get nibbled on
by mark
when you think how many
millions of sharks
are taken for us to nibble on them
to turn them into soup to turn them into
shark steak or even
which really baffles me people kill
sharks for the fun of it at their
tournaments to see how many sharks you
can kill
in the process they're really killing
the ocean because this ocean really
needs sharks well and what about just
like
tuna and salmon and other common uh food
fishing i mean have we brought that
overfishing under control or is it still
getting worse oh my goodness no you know
90 of the sharks are gone in some cases
like the oceanic whitetip and the short
fin mako they're down to half of one
percent of what they were when i was a
kid we're really good at killing them
and that's disrupted not just the food
chains
the ecology of the ocean but the
chemistry of the ocean the carbon cycle
is disrupted too
because carbon is part of that cycle
nutrients are given back by every living
creature every animal gives nutrients
back whether it's a whale or a shark or
a tuna
and when we take so many of them out of
the ocean
we
we alter
the chemistry of the ocean
and that ultimately comes around to
the oxygen that's generated the carbon
that's captured
but more than that the excess
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
has turned to carbonic acid
in the ocean you know the atmosphere
is one putting excess carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere driving the warming of
the planet that's one category of woe
but the other is excess carbon dioxide
in the ocean
is turning the ocean more acidic acidic
right again changing the chemistry
so
although
it's obvious
that our impact by the direct killing
of ocean
wildlife tunas swordfish
crabs lobster shrimp
cod you name it anything
in the ocean
any animal there is a wild animal
and
we we have reduced their populations
the ones that appear
in our supermarkets and restaurants
dramatically
in
a matter of decades
so that the numbers for bluefin tuna
in the pacific
we're down to about three percent of
what was there in 1970
in the atlantic
it's a little better perhaps maybe 10
percent
of the blue fins
in terms of their
numbers
as compared to what was there
in
1970
i remarked on this when i was
at noaa as the chief scientist because
that was
only 20 years
into the you know 1990 and i said in 20
years we were able to reduce the
population by about 90 percent
in
the atlantic
and my comment was what are we trying to
do exterminate them because we're doing
a good job only 10 left
yeah and that's when they started
calling me the sturgeon
but you know
somebody has to speak for the fish
because most people don't know
they see an animal in the supermarket
they figure that somebody's looking out
for
their numbers and that it's got to be
all right if it's
if it's in
a restaurant
but
the fact is
we have
we have
habits customs and laws in place
governing our behavior toward the ocean
as it was
it doesn't really necessarily
fit the ocean
as it is
today
so much has changed so fast
that
it's a different ocean today than what
it was when i was a child i mean in some
ways it's good we've got more whales
we've got more sea turtles because we
started protecting them but in almost
every other
thing that you look at coral reefs are
only about half remaining
mangroves
sea grasses
populations of oysters
that once were so abundant in new york
and in the chesapeake bay the gulf of
mexico
they're just a tiny fraction remaining
san francisco bay
for lots of reasons not not just because
we love to eat them but but because
we've altered the nature of the ocean
itself it's not as friendly a place
for
life as we knew it and experienced it
when i was a kid well in terms of the
fish just you know especially tuna
swordfish etc what would you recommend
that our policy be either individually
or
as as nations in the world it sounds
from what you're saying that you would
hope that we should pretty dramatically
change our habits when it comes to uh
eating seafood
i say give them a break
it's a choice yeah we don't really need
i i try hard to think who on the planet
really
needs
to eat
ocean wildlife for sustenance because
they don't have many choices whether
there are
communities
island countries
where
they're
it's not just a choice it's their their
existence
they're food sources it's like bushmeat
they're people on the land who really
rely on wildlife
for sustenance
and in most cases
those who are in that category have had
a peaceful
relationship with nature over a very
long period of time they take but they
don't take so much that the population
that they rely on for sustenance
collapses
well that's not the state for most of
the world and that's not the rationale
for
most of what is taken from the ocean
it's more about offering a choice a
luxury choice to people
who have you know
for whom
orange roughy chilean sea bass
uh many things that we take from the
ocean wild things from the ocean
are either new on their menu or in any
case
they're not
a need it's a choice and usually it's a
luxury choice
the cost of
of choosing fish today
is truly a luxury choice
so
i
the the basic getting to the the heart
of the problem is that
we regard
wild things as free things
just there's zero accounting base
when you calculate
the the worth of wild animals
they are only valuable once you've
captured them
and taken them to market then they then
you can put a price tag on them but
swimming in the ocean
they're not only free for the taking
there's no cost except getting there and
extracting them there is cost to that
but
curiously taxpayers whether they know it
or not
are subsidizing
the extravagant
capturing of
wildlife from the ocean and there's a
cost that we're just beginning to
account for too and that's called
bycatch
that in order to have shrimp on your
plate or tuna in your sushi or in your
salad
there
are many tons of other creatures
who are caught in the process
and are simply discarded
using bottom trawls
those big nets that scrape the ocean
floor
for those who live not only close to the
bottom but and that's shrimp
they're bottom dwellers
halibut
flounder their bottom dwellers
and many others as well
are captured in this way where you take
everything it's like dragging a net
across new york city or or san francisco
you take up everything and you shake out
the few things that you want the
pedestrians maybe and all the rest is
just
thrown away right killed
lost
it's like bulldozing a forest to get the
songbirds
and
we condone that
we have been doing this now for decades
and
we're paying the cost the ocean
is
seriously disrupted
just from this one form of capturing
ocean wildlife that not only is bad for
the creatures they catch but for this
whole ecosystem that gets destroyed in
the process
and we don't account for the loss
it's all considered to be the cost of
doing business at no cost
so all of us are paying because we have
an ocean that we need for our existence
our health our security
that is being
torn apart
because we simply haven't understood
the the real consequences we thought the
ocean was too big
to fail no matter what we took out of it
or however we took what we took i mean
consider
what we did during
the 1950s and beyond
to test nuclear devices in the ocean
blowing up whole chunks of ocean with
all the creatures who live there
in some of the most
beautiful and productive coral reefs on
the planet were simply vaporized well
we we can
in a way justify it as well it's war
and it's
security
well
okay
we didn't know then as much as we do now
about what real security means
if we disrupt the systems on this
little blue spec in the universe it's
pretty unfriendly except for here
we're in trouble
and we have disrupted
the systems
that maintain earth is a habitable place
in a universe it's not very friendly
but
we we can see it
we know it we can measure it and we also
know what to do
to turn things from decline
that i've been a witness to and people
have been seeing now through decades and
we
have the alarm bells running ringing and
flashing you know
we've got climate issues we've got
warming issues we've got pollution
issues we've got a diminishing
population of
tuna and swordfish and all the other
creatures we extract from the sea
but what is the solution
well the great positive thing is
now we know
we know what to do
we need to make better choices about
what we eat how we
treat the ocean
and
to
use this
remarkable time in history of humankind
to apply what we now know
that we could not know
not so long ago
that's the
superpower
of knowing
that leads to
understanding and
shifting in a way that will make
make us safe
we need a planet that really works in
our favor and we've had it through all
my life but when i think about
my kids my grandkids
all everybody's grandkids
the if we continue the current
trajectory of decline
their future looks
pretty perilous
but
we've got this
little window right now this is the
sweet spot in time
because we're armed with knowing
cause and effect
i mean they're smart whales they're
they're smart birds
fellow primates i i've met some pretty
smart fish
but
they cannot know
what today's kids and grown-ups too
know
what earth looks like from space
to see that everything connects
you know we can't get away with doing
bad behavior anywhere without it
affecting now we know
everywhere
so that
fires in australia
affect me here in california and vice
versa fires in california
affect the whole planet
because everything connects
and good behavior connects too
so that when we protect
with a national park
protect a water system
protect
the flyways of birds
go from not just one part of a country
but across boundaries into other
countries
working together
birds are safer now than they were at
some points in
times past because we're
we we value them and we're taking
measures to protect them
and we're beginning to understand that
the same is true with fish
that we can't feed ourselves with wild
birds songbirds
we'd soon run out of groceries if we all
had to just eat songbirds
but we're running out of fish too why
because we've taken so many so fast with
industrial technologies
that enable us
to extract wildlife on a on this huge
scale
and it affects the nature of life in the
ocean affects the chemistry of the ocean
it affects us
and
of course people
one way or the other
we'll take life from the ocean
to eat but
we need to think about how much how fast
and what methods are being used and even
with aquaculture we've got to get much
smarter about how we do that
raising carnivores really doesn't make
any sense
you know
if you've got a big fish like a salmon
what does it eat it eats other fish that
eat other fish that eat other fish and
you get down to plants ultimately
so
cows are taking a big bite out of the
ecosystem even though they eat plants
but at least
it's
sunlight plant cow
sunlight plant chicken
sunlight plant sheep sunlight you know
all the animals we raise to eat are
grazers by nature
most of the animals we take from the
ocean the wild animals and even those
that are being cultivated
largely
carnivores yeah
and salmon is the number one example
catfish better choice they eat plants
and they grow fast unlike a tunas it
takes
many years just to mature and can live
you know 30 40 50 years
so
we're eating
these old fish that have accumulated
whatever we put in the ocean
so the older they are the bigger the
fish
the greater the likelihood they've got
stuff in them
that you probably don't want in you
and they're more valuable in the ocean
doing their thing like wolves and lions
and tigers
than
than on our plates we have so many
choices
about
what we can eat
i remember visiting the monterey bay
aquarium and they handed out these
little cards which basically
recommend please don't eat these please
do eat these and but i guess i i always
thought of that in terms of how
endangered the species were but i i
hadn't thought of it in terms of where
they are in the food chain which is what
you're suggesting well that's one of the
bigger missions of these
uh
guides
about better choices
failure to acknowledge the age
the investment that goes into
making even a little fish because
a chicken that's been around for less
than a year and goes to market has
consumed about two pounds of plants
a tuna that gets big enough to go to
market
has consumed when you go through the
food chain
fish that have eaten fish leaving how
many
tons of
phytoplankton
at the bottom of the food chain
capturing sunlight turning it into
food
goes in ultimately to making a tuna
we're talking thousands of pounds of
plants
for one pound of tuna for a cow it's
about 20 pounds
of
photosynthesizers
to make
a pound of cow
about two pounds for a pound of chicken
but any
wild fish but especially the big old
carnivores the top carnivores that we
especially like to eat whether it's a
cod
or swordfish or a 50 year old halibut
right think about
an animal that has
has escaped all the things in the ocean
that have enabled it to get to be a 50
year old
halibut a big old fish
that then gets sliced and diced to
become a little
piece of meat on your plate
and you just eat it casually if you do
eat halibut or tuna or swordfish or cod
do so with great respect right because
it's taking a huge bite out of
the ocean
and we aren't properly accounting for
the cost no matter how much you pay for
that
wondrous yeah so that is
a very good perspective i think the uh
the whole top of the food chain kind of
thing i do want to give us a chance to
just say a little bit about
climate change uh and
i think probably most people listening
agree that climate change is real it's
largely caused by anthropogenic
activities and presumably it's bad for
the oceans but maybe less appreciated is
the sort of feedback
element going on right that uh that uh
climate change affects the oceans and
the oceans affect climate change i i
remember hearing very recently worries
that the gulf stream might be
disappearing entirely because of climate
change it's a very unpredictable system
i mean is there is there anything that
you that you think that we should know
that maybe we don't about the
relationship of climate change and the
oceans well
again
i feel so
fortunate to have
the opportunity to kick back
and
and
thoughtfully look at what we now know
and i'm not alone in doing this with
scientists around the world who are
addressing climate
are for the first time
able to
gather the information that's been
accumulating now
for decades
that are
enabling us to see what we couldn't see
before
connecting the dots looking at patterns
cause and effect
one thing seems
really obvious now
that maybe wasn't so obvious when
concerns about
changing climate first began to make
headlines
and that is we're talking about a living
system
whether it's trees capturing carbon and
sequestering carbon
or
phytoplankton in the ocean
that is doing the same thing capturing
carbon dioxide
generating food
releasing oxygen but sequestering
carbon when
carbon
whether it's in the roots of
a rain forest tree or a tree in your
backyard you're sequestering
carbon into the soil
mangroves are champion carbon sequesters
with their roots
in the ocean
and
not only generating oxygen capturing
carbon keeping the carbon right in place
now think about this
the hundreds of millions of tons
of
carbon-based units we call squid and
shrimp and
tuna and swordfish and all the other
creatures that we extract from the ocean
that carbon
goes back to the atmosphere
similarly when you clear-cut
or burn a forest what happens to the
carbon
into the atmosphere that's bad but
what's worse
is
that the natural
carbon capturing systems that have
shaped earth into a habitable place for
life as we know it
are destroyed
or diminished
or corrupted one way or the other
and
that has not really been
acknowledged so much in the past i mean
more with trees than with the ocean but
now blue carbon
is
making headlines if you will okay
international monetary fund commissioned
a study
that was reported at the world economic
forum in davos
in 2020 about the value the carbon
capturing and sequestration value of
whales to be
on the order of a trillion dollars yeah
pretty good that's real money justin
just thinking about their other values i
mean we love whales we love their songs
we love their
i mean all these
intangibles but
then there's whale watching and then
there's this and that the other the
what's the value of a live whale
compared to the dead whale well
dead whale puts carbon back into the
atmosphere
live oil holds it in place and
ultimately
goes to the bottom of the ocean that's
how it has worked
long before humans were around
that this cycle
scientists tend to
follow the carbon
[Laughter]
if you really want to understand
climate yeah
economists follow the money right the
scientists
follow the carbon follow the water
follow this but look at how the system
functions
and
in scotland at the climate conference
that's
forthcoming in october
for the
first time
instead of just being
acknowledged a little bit
that in paris was the first time that
the ocean as a component of climate was
acknowledged at all before it's all
about the atmosphere it's all about the
land
but think of this now we know because it
seems obvious
the ocean drives
climate
moves cold water and warm water around
the planet
shapes
the planet's climate without the ocean
there would be no climate effectively
and we've just haven't thought about it
now we are thinking about it yeah and
now we're acknowledging not just rocks
and water not just the heat
holding capacity of the ocean and not
just ocean currents moving around but
the living ocean
the carbon in the ocean as
as a principal driver
of
of the cycle of life of the climate
when you think if earth
did not
it had had rocks and water
but had no life
would be a really
inhospitable place
[Laughter]
it's
it's the living
complicated
interacting systems in the land and in
the sea in the soil
in the
in the fabric of life itself that we fit
into this
as a as a piece of it and now we become
a dominantly
influential piece because of our
capacity to alter the nature of nature
and knowing this means
oh
this is what we have to do
to heal the harm
here's how we repair
what we've done to damage the network of
life
we know that planting trees not just any
old trees
the right trees the native trees and the
right places in the right way at the
right time
we can be a positive difference
make a positive we plant native plants
instead of a lawn
in our the area if you have a yard
think about what you can do to restore
insects and birds and life on the land
the carbon cycle
by being
by being a good steward of that little
piece of land and you can do what
your part or a community
you work with your your neighbors work
with those
to plan
use of the land in a way that's water
friendly
instead of
paving over
streams
and putting them in culverts because
it's efficient
think about the cost to what you're
losing
in the process
you know working with nature
seems like such a simple
but beautiful idea
to understand
where have we caused a problem how can
we be a solution
and you can do it
one person at a time or a community
or country
thinking about the commitment that
countries are making all over the world
now including
this country
to embrace the natural systems land and
sea
to protect at least 30 percent in the
next 10 years at least 30 percent
and to have respect for literally the
whole
earth system because
that's what keeps us alive
astronauts
they care about their life support
system i do when i go down on a
submarine i'm going to be careful of the
air and the water whatever food i've got
well
on a planetary scale this is the first
time
lucky us
we have this superpower
of understanding what nobody could see
when i was a kid and the kids of today
have got this
gift of knowledge that is being
handed over to them
and of course we're handing them some
big problems too well yes
those are the solutions i mean if i were
a kid i'd say
yes this is my time i've got this is the
best time ever because i know what to do
let me let me add it
you know i i always like to sort of all
the help we can to wrap up the podcast
on an optimistic note and you do this
instinctively so i don't even have to
you know nudge you in that direction
this is also very optimistic things you
just said but let me just give you the
opportunity to elaborate a little bit on
something you mentioned very quickly
there this idea of protected areas
under the sea um is this something well
number one
how does that work i mean the sea is all
like the water just sort of flows into
other areas of the water so is it even
feasible to protect areas of the sea and
number two is it something we're doing
or or should be doing is it something we
should be agitating for
the national park idea got underway
early in the 20th century
and late in the 20th century the idea of
doing something comparable in the ocean
took place first in australia with a
great barrier reef marine park authority
to protect that amazing coral reef that
borders
the east coast of australia
and
in the united states about the same time
a little place was protected around
a shipwreck off the coast of north
carolina the monitor
as a historic monument or protected area
but also in the florida keys
and since then around the world
the
nations have scaled up significantly
the the concept of protection
in areas under their jurisdiction within
the exclusive economic zones
the countries have
have
the ability to govern out 200 nautical
miles
so this country united states
is twice as big if you count that what
most people think of it if you count the
blue part and some countries little
island countries are
10 20 100 times bigger than the land
mass
but it's under their jurisdiction so
all of that
is we're seeing some real progress not
enough but the goal is
thirty percent by twenty thirty right
now it's about three percent okay but
going back going back 20 years it was
zero percent so
that'd be a huge one almost it was very
so almost couldn't measure it in the
greater scheme of the ocean
but
if you count some of the areas that have
some form of protection like our marine
sanctuaries
and places around the world that are
managed but you can still commercially
fish and do a lot of other stuff they're
not really protected but they're they're
moving in the right direction
maybe
maybe close to 10
of the ocean has some form of protection
but the goal by 2030 is full protection
for 30 of the land and the ocean it's
our bank account it's our insurance
policy
against the natural ups and downs
that will take place no matter what
humans do
i mean
it's
it seems like the smartest investment we
could possibly make and the more
some are
and i'm among them are aiming for at
least half of the world i mean okay to
to protect our life support system yeah
doesn't mean we can trash the rest and
get away with it
i mean half of your heart do you want
just half of your heart to function
[Music]
what do you want to really protect all
of it
one way or the other of course
we we will use nature all creatures do
we'll we'll divert the water for our
purposes
we will
you know we've already clear-cut so much
of the land we ought to be
reusing those places and restoring what
we can to better health right including
our own backyards i mean that's a good
place to start
for people you know look around what's
within your personal scope
you too can plant a tree
yeah yeah where you can
you know
lawns are
we've come to think of them as kind of
beautiful like a rogue out when you're
outside of your house but
think about what wildflowers would look
like natives
think about what a vegetable garden
would look like it's good for you
in terms of what you eat what you know
and
good for the
good for the land good for the air think
of
generating oxygen and capturing carbon
and then you consume some of it yourself
and
i
i just so excited about
the
things that we know we can do to make
the world a better place nobody can do
it all but everybody can do something so
it all starts with
that individual you see in the mirror
yeah it's a very good message you're
willing to step up why would you expect
others
it reminds me very much of
a podcast they did a couple years ago
with joe walston who was a
conservationist and he had a very
optimistic message that you know he's on
land rather than on the sea but you know
he he thinks that if we put enough
people into cities and protect enough of
the land outside the cities we can
actually live in a happy equilibrium but
but he stressed the point that there is
a race you know there's a we we have to
get to the happy place before we destroy
things to an irreparable irrecoverable
point and it sounds like the same thing
is true for the ocean so i think that's
a good call to action
uh for everyone out there listening
right so
i i say
celebrate if you had to choose a time
in all of history
it would be fun to go back
hundreds or thousands of years ago or
maybe to zoom forward and see what it
all turns out to be but
i think this is
this is the best choice
you
we all of us together
are at a pivotal
time right with what we do or fail to do
but i hope it's in a positive way
because we know
that it makes a difference we know we've
seen the evidence
when we embrace nature with care we get
positive results
we get more whales we get more trees we
have a better quality of air
we can
restore
better quality to
the water that we didn't know the harm
we are capable of inflicting
in the past but there's no excuse today
now we know
and we should celebrate that
it really is our superpower i think
and it can save us
it can and it is a superpower and it's a
very good message so i can't think of
any place to wrap up in that so sylvia
earle thanks very very much for being on
the weinstein podcast oh thank you for
having me on board
[Music]
so
[Music]
you